Just like buses, on the same day that we
got GPT40 image gen and a new DeepSeek
V3, we also got Gemini 2.5 Pro. There is
no ultra or nano version, but we're
still calling it Pro, but it is out and
some at Google are claiming that it is
the best AI language model out there.
I've been testing out a fair bit myself
and yes, this is normally where I would
say and I've read the paper, but unlike
the new openweight Deep Seek V3 Gemini
2.5 secret source is being kept secret.
Beyond the benchmarks though, there is a
bigger story here of wider interest.
Just recently, the CEO of Microsoft has
claimed that models are being
commoditized with greater performance
bought like commodities and that labs
like OpenAI are merely quote product
companies selling an experience. He's
saying that they no more have the secret
to quote AGI than anyone else. Let's set
aside for a moment the fact that the new
GPT40 image gen from OpenAI is very much
a model as well as a product. Is the
bigger point correct? Does today's
Gemini 2.5 and Deepseek V3 news prove
that there is no secret to AI anymore?
At least when it comes to intelligence.
To answer that, let's start with the
brand new Gemini 2.5, Google's quote
most intelligent AI model. Notice that
this title is a little more humble,
saying it's their most intelligent model
rather than flatout the smartest model
around. I'll be honest, I didn't see
this model coming, and I don't think too
many people did either. coming so soon
after Gemini 2. But here it is. All the
benchmark figures can be a little bit
overwhelming, so I'm going to try and
help you understand what some of them
mean. The somewhat amusingly
misconceived title of humanity's last
exam is an incredibly knowledge inensive
benchmark. Of course, you do need to
reason and calculate for some of the
questions. But most of all, it's testing
incredibly obscure trivia, difficult
Latin translations, and obstruuse
butterfly physiology. But credit where
credit is due, Gemini 2.5 seems to know
the most. One thing to bear in mind, of
course, is that the full O3 hasn't been
released yet. This is just 03 mini from
OpenAI. So, one would suspect that the
full O3 will score more highly than
this. One hint at that is that the deep
research system, albeit using tools,
gets around 27% on this benchmark. For
knowledge without searching the web,
Gemini 2.5 Pro knows the most, you could
say. What about incredibly difficult
science questions? Google proof PhD
level questions. Again, on that front,
notice the convergence with 2.5 Pro
being more or less level with claw 3.7
Sonic just a shade under when it uses
extended thinking. And likewise for
Grock 3. Now, if you want to be harsh,
you could note the fact that they didn't
include 03, even though we know the
score of that model using majority
voting, which is
87.7%. But Google slightly call out
OpenAI there saying our schools are
without things like majority voting
which expend even more compute. But in a
way, I've got to say that's kind of the
point of this video, which is this word
leads. Does anyone really lead anymore?
As someone who analyzes AI, making
direct comparisons is increasingly and
you could say deliberately made more
difficult. Some companies like OpenAI
use majority voting for their benchmark
scores. Others just don't report the
benchmarks in which they perform worse
at. Some figures you see include the use
of tools, others don't. But even with
all of that said, the scores are
slightly converging. For a given amount
of compute, you get roughly around a
certain level of performance in say
mathematics or science or knowledge
trivia or even coding. That's not to say
that anyone watching can't have a clear
favorite model. I would argue probably
03 might be just about the best all
round and I use deep research all the
time. Many people love the personality
and writing style of Claude 3.7 Sonnet
and use it extensively for coding in
things like cursor. Deepseek and we'll
come on to them are absolutely pushing
the limits when it comes to cost
efficiency. The best bang for your buck
if that's your main criterion. But if
you keep compute expenditures level,
performance is really starting to
converge. And that's the big revelation
of tonight for me. It is very much worth
pointing out that that does not preclude
the fact that models are improving. It's
just that they're improving together. I
love the fact that models can now read
tables and charts in, for example, the
MMU benchmark better than ever. In this
case, Gemini 2.5 Pro is literally
state-of-the-art. And its excellence in
that particular category was reinforced
by the Vista benchmark from Scale AI.
Unlike the mmu which is multiple choice,
the Vista benchmark gives the model a
free form response. And as makes sense
for visual understanding, it tests
things like can you count how many
things there are in an image, can you
use logic, can you extract information,
and not only is Gemini 2.5 Pro a huge
step above even Claude 3.7 in this
capacity, it's actually the first model
to get within touching distance of human
performance in this benchmark. And those
humans, by the way, were able to browse
the web and take their time to answer.
So that performance is pretty
impressive. One quick benchmark I should
include, even though it's slightly
problematic, is the huge jump on the
language model arena. Yes, it's
community voted and it can be slightly
gamed, but it is a huge delta now
between number one and number two. The
eagle-eyed among you though may be
noticing one big red flag about this
benchmark which is where on earth is
clawed 3.7 set. I have got to admit that
in one area Gemini 2.5 Pro is just head
and shoulders above other models and
that is in long context. It can handle a
million tokens. That's roughly let's say
750,000 words when the other models in
this chart can't even handle a quarter
of that. But I would still argue that
with one or two exceptions, performance
across the board is converging between
diverse model families. It's currently
free, by the way, in Google's AI studio,
but that of course won't last. And it is
able to search, which is great, except
that Chat GBT has been able to do that
for quite a while, and so too will
Claude very soon. Just quickly, how does
it do on my benchmark, Simplebench? A
test of common sense reasoning, or some
would say trick questions. We're hoping
to sometime very late tonight. I mean,
what is it now? Approaching 10:30.
Hopefully get it done and on the
leaderboard. But I couldn't resist
testing it on the 10 public questions.
Gemini 2 Pro, even Gemini 2 thinking
only got one out of 10. Gemini 2.5 Pro,
and you can test yourself on the
questions if you like, gets five out of
10, which is a huge jump. Only thing is
that's what Claude 3.7 gets. And 01.
That's again kind of the point of the
video. Not that progress isn't being
made and we can talk about that all day,
more that model performance is
converging. But now we must come to the
new Deep Seek V3 announced this morning.
And that's not the new reasoning model.
That's not R2. It's a new base model.
You can think of it for a reasoning
model. The best analogy is comparing it
to GPT 4.5, which should be the base
model for GPT5, which will be a
reasoning model, just like GPT 4 is kind
of the base model behind the O series of
models. And let me zoom into the chart
because this perhaps is the starkkest
evidence that performance is converging
across teams. Today's Deepseek V3 is in
stripes and that is what will surely be
the base model for the R2 model coming
probably in the next few weeks. Now, not
only do I want you to focus on the
improvement from the original Deepseek
V3, which is the underlying model of R1,
but also focus on the comparison with
GPT 4.5 from OpenAI. It seems starkly
better in mathematics, as you can see,
and arguably so in coding, just
underperforming slightly for science
questions and general knowledge. But
remember, OpenAI was supposed to be 6 or
12 months or more ahead of Chinese
companies. Now, the base models between
the new Deep Seek V3 and Gypsy 4.5 are
kind of on par. 4.5, don't forget, is
the model that Samman said many people
will feel the AGI for. Now, on my
Patreon, I'm going to be imminently
releasing a documentary on the behind
the scenes of Deep Seek and Leang
Wenfang, but I doubt he would say he's
going to feel the AGI on this new V3.
And yes, of course, I'm aware that
unless they're backed by the Chinese
state, and even then, Deepseek might
struggle to match the sheer compute of
anthropic or open AAI. But nevertheless,
as things currently stand, there is for
reasoning models no clear moat. Before
we finish, then two more cheeky bits of
evidence for the commoditization of AI.
Commoditization here being the argument
that the only real differentiator at the
moment is how much money you can funnel
to getting more compute which then
increments your benchmark performance.
Now we have already talked about how
Satiana has said that directly AI models
are getting commoditized and as anyone
who's watched this channel for a while
you will know that that's a huge vibe
shift from 2 years ago when he was
celebrating the fact that he had this
special partnership with OpenAI. But a
couple weeks back, we got this insider
report in the information which I
couldn't find a chance to talk about on
the channel, but is really interesting.
There is a unit within Microsoft called
Microsoft AI and it's run by this guy
Mustafa Sulleon, formerly the head of
Inflection AI and before that the
co-founder of Google DeepMind along with
Dems. As you might expect, the Microsoft
AI unit is also trying to fashion AGI.
But then last September they noticed 01
of course from OpenAI leap ahead and we
all did. Mustafa Sulleon apparently
called up and got very angry when OpenAI
wouldn't tell him how they'd made it. He
started to raise his voice at Mirror
Mirati. Apparently you're not holding up
your end of the deal. He said the call
ended abruptly. give us the
documentation, he demanded about how you
had programmed 01 to think about user
queries before answering. Now, obviously
that's a somewhat juicy story of the
failing relationship between Microsoft
and OpenAI. But the real nugget comes
later. According to Microsoft at least,
they have figured it out how to do this
kind of reasoning like Gemini and R1 and
the rest of it, Gro 3 and 03 and
everyone seems to be reasoning now, but
so are Microsoft apparently. and they
claim that their MAI models now perform
nearly as well as leading models from
OpenAI and Anthropic on benchmarks.
Their models of course also do this
thinking before answering. Is that why
Satia and Adella so confidently said
that models are being commoditized? If
his own team is able to even partially
replicate the performance of say 03,
then that would indeed give him that
confidence to say that. Now it's not
like Microsoft needs to have the best
model. They are making a ton of money
off AI in all sorts of directions. For
example, did you know according to the
972 magazine, sales of the company's
cloud and AI services to the Israeli
army have skyrocketed since the
beginning of its onslaught on Gaza. And
of course, we'll have to wait and see if
the MAI models live up to the hype. But
nevertheless, the statement alone is
noteworthy. Do you feel OpenAI is just a
product company? I think it's more than
that, but time will tell. The final bit
of cheeky evidence comes from again
comparing Deepseek V3, the new one from
today with Claude 3.7 Sonnet. As we
know, these are just five benchmarks out
of the probably hundred or so out there
now. But just on say live codebench, it
outperforms 3.7 sonnet. And that comes
just days after the CEO of Anthropic
made this comment. Um what we are
finding is we are not far from the
world. Well, I think we'll be there in 3
to 6 months where AI is writing 90% of
the code and then in 12 months we may be
in a world where AI is writing
essentially all of the code. But I must
confess to noticing after I saw that
rather dramatic and hypy comment that
Anthropic are still advertising for
software engineering roles in my
hometown of London. Not only that, they
are advertising annual salaries of very
generous proportions. But wait, if
Claude four or five within 12 months is
going to do quote all the coding, then
why even advertise an annual salary?
Logically, these people would be out of
a job within a few months. Yes, I'm
being somewhat facitious because of
course engineering is much more than
just coding. But still, the words and
the prediction don't quite match the
recruitment intensity. And for a family
of models that is set to do quote all
the coding, it sure is struggling with a
primary school age game, in this case
playing Pokémon, endlessly getting stuck
and resorting to hilarious means to
progress and never quite doing so. So
that is my take on the new Gemini. An
amazing model, but more proof of
convergence than exceptionality. Of
course, very awkward for the Gemini team
that it came on the same night as Image
Gen from OpenAI. I decided to do two
separate videos. So, let me know if you
like that approach. I thought it would
just make it easier for you guys to
share it with friends if they're
interested in one topic or the other.
But, as it is approaching 11:00 here, I
must bid you good night. Thank you so
much for watching and have a wonderful